adele
music
adele
i invite you to join me for one night
only how posh is this it's gonna be a
very special night a first look at adele
one night only just dropped and it
is
everything
the two-hour cbs prime time special will
air on sunday november 14th but on
thursday fans got a sneak peek at the 33
year old singer's performance which was
filmed in los angeles at the griffith
observatory being in la as well where i
sort of
had to
recover you know from from everything
that happened in my life over the last
few years just sort of felt the perfect
perfect show it will look really elegant
and then i'll tell like a load of filthy
jokes sort of whiplash for him and based
on the clip we can expect to hear some
of the classics like rolling in the deep
[Music]
and sky falls
the special will also feature a few new
tracks off of adele's highly anticipated
new album 30 which is set to drop on
november 19th
i'm obviously going to hear a lot of
older songs and then four new songs
and the event was star-studded i flew
all the way across the country just to
be here what an incredible
evening yep that's tyler perry and james
corden who we know is a pretty
supportive friend during adele's
interview with vogue she revealed the
late late show host gifted her with a um
special momento from her favorite singer
celine dion
james corden who's a friend of mine but
also does carpool karaoke which i did
he did it with her and knew how much a
fan of of her i was and so he made her
spit her gum into piece of paper and he
framed it for me
and it's my proudest possession anyway
gabrielle union and dwyane wade were in
attendance as was lizzo
also get you lizzo you can come out
shine me babes e.t recently chatted with
gail king who attended the taping too
and she teased what fans can expect she
sounds like the adele that you know and
love i mean i i believe nobody has a
voice like hers nobody
nobody and she did not disappoint but
she just looked so good
the dress she was wearing made me think
i'm going to give up eating cupcakes
until the next day of course in addition
to her performance the special will
feature a candid conversation with
gail's bestie oprah winfrey and while
the news anchor played coy about the
interview she did say this i've just
heard from reliable sources it went very
very well the sit down marks the grammy
winner's first televised wide-ranging
conversation about her album the stories
behind the songs life after divorce from
her ex simon kaneki weight loss and
raising her nine-year-old son absolutely
yeah and in a sneak peek at their chat
adele reveals she kicks the whole show
off with her hit single hello
that song means so much to people all
around the world it does yeah so what
does it represent to you
well the show is the first time that i
you know that
i'm singing it
from where i am now yes which i think is
great
um the song to me
was
the beginning of me trying to find
myself and i hadn't figured out yet what
it was that i had to do for that but
when i wrote it it was a real ode to
like
little me older me like all of these
things like you know so
it's just a song about like i'm still
here
you know it's sort of like hi i'm still
here like i still exist like you know in
every aspect of my life as for oprah she
explains why she was so interested in
interviewing adele why
was this an interview i was interested
in because i'm always interested in
people who are willing to speak their
truth she actually is the truth couldn't
have said it better myself and to send
you off here's a little peek at adele
performing rolling in the deep to get us
through to sunday there's a fire
starting in my heart reaching a fever
pitching is bringing me out the dark
finally i can see you crystal clear